hello everybody and welcome back to life
jesus honey from podcasts
you guys welcome back to another episode
we are
happy to be here happy tuesday everyone
we are currently
in florida right now and to say
that i am happy is an understatement are
you happy
i'm elated to be here you know our
parents are here and
we have our dogs here just
especially during the pandemic we were
at home in l.a for a bit
and i don't know it just felt like sad
i can tell i totally agree i definitely
took my family and the dogs for granted
because
not like that no no i mean i'll say what
i
this is my experience sister
i you know thought the idea of being on
your own
and living alone and doing that whole
thing is really exciting
but once you do it it's so lonely yeah
and i i sort of feel like it's the same
way when people go off to college and
they're living in a dorm for the first
time
you think it's going to be great and
trust me it has its moments it's great
but
it was just really quiet and i missed
them so much
you know what also i think that a lot of
people don't i don't know if you guys
all have experiences like this but our
family is a very loud family
so no matter what time of day it is
whether it is
seven in the morning to 12 o'clock at
night our talking is screaming
and our talking is a storytelling
anything that's very very loud yeah
and honestly when people come over i
swear to god they think we're fighting
with each other they're like i'm so
sorry like i was kind of in the middle
that was like no
that was just that's like having a
conversation so when it was just
the two of us in our house in l.a it was
really really
quiet i mean like we can figure out each
other all day but you know
not having mom as the mediator was a big
thing because normally my mom will say
who won the fight
and that the other one just passed about
i don't know so like who's
like so we kind of have to come back i
gotta work
oh god but it's been really nice the
best part i think about having uh
us being here is the restaurants but i
because the restaurants are open la all
the dining is closed
indoor outdoor um it's really sad
there's a lot of cases going on in
california but
in florida it's a little bit different
but um obviously we're keeping it safe
we're in the masks doing that whole
thing
um but i had to kind of expose you for a
second because i know you don't know i
don't know if you want to talk about
this on the podcast i don't hate when
you do that i'm sorry okay i'm gonna
like shock her on this
uh sister what do you tell what happened
in the restaurant last night
[ __ ] all right you guys hilarious this
is great
i bought these new shoes right and they
are giant chunky heels and normally when
you have a chunky heel ladies
you know what i mean like very stable
you can walk in them you can run in them
platform shoes the way to go i feel so
good
i'm strutting they're probably like nine
inches tall they're huge really big
guys they're like platform yeah with the
chunky heel i feel like lady gaga on
these shoes so i'm walking out and
as a and it's crowded yeah it's crowded
like there's a crack tonight
i'm walking out and i slip
on the floor because it was like a soft
spot
and i completely wipe out
not like a cute little tumble like
it was like a cartoon fall like arms
flailing backwards
guys and the fall lasted like four or
five seconds it was
i was right behind her and she's in
front of me that her feet
were shuffling like slide slides
honestly imagine yourself on skates for
the first time
you can't get your group like you're
running in snow but that front door
i almost slipped too the ground was it
was like this what's what's that
material on the ground it's like
it's not carpeted it's like a not marble
stone it's maybe it's a stone but like
it just did not work out with shoes in
general no grip there
no i fall into this guy who just my luck
happens to be
super super hot in my
and um i fall into him and he catches me
from like two inches from hitting the
ground like that's how bad of a fall it
was yeah it wasn't a cute fall his
girlfriend looks at me
very angry if i was trying
to like flirty bump into him
it would be a lot cuter like my hair was
in front of my face like it was so bad
and he laughed and i said and i'm here
to tell you
it was not cute at all like it was
so embarrassing
yeah thank you samia thank you that was
the worst part i walked out
instead of sofia asking oh my god are
you okay right
first thing she says she goes dude that
was
so embarrassing yeah i know
[ __ ] thanks thanks but you know
okay i know a couple episodes back we
talked about haunted clothing like if
you go on a bad date
you can't wear that dress anymore
because it's haunted or whatever yeah i
swear
i'm like i feel the same way about these
shoes they're cursed i'm terrified to
wear them again
i know you say that the shoes are
totally cursing like probably shouldn't
i've had like outfits where i've worn a
dress
and i shattered my hand on the glass and
there was like blood all over the dress
and i was kind of grossed off but i
haven't worn the dress since
and now i feel like i should like wear
it to redeem it and still isolaze here
you should wear the shoes here's an idea
maybe don't wear the dress if there's
old blood stains on it
okay so she thinks i'm gonna go out with
the dress and still have the blood
stains on it like
i'm um what's her name carrie probably
um anyway uh i hope people out there can
relate to what i'm about to say but i
have this weird thought sophia and i
were just on a plane
and does anyone else think this that
whenever they see
a person of the opposite sex on a plane
that's your age like there's always some
weird sexual
tension is that yeah wait hold on a
little bit better
so say for example like i'm sitting on a
plane and there's like another 22 year
old guy
and like you guys are both staring at
each other it's almost like wait like
you guys
you always automatically recognize
someone your
age or like around your age i always
think that's so cool
it's almost it's one of those places
like a coffee shop where
if you're sitting having your coffee and
someone else is sitting over there
having your coffee
you feel you make eye contact it's
almost like you want
the meat cute to happen it's almost like
people assume that you could
meet that person totally or it's like
the exact opposite where
it's so awkward and it's even worse when
they sit next to you and you're like
do we talk because we're the same age or
do we just pretend like
yeah no i i i don't know maybe because
it's the morning and people don't like
like like to see each other because
they're i mean i sat next to a guy on a
plane one time
and she did that was my age she did or
no he was a few years older
and it ended up being like a super great
meet cute and we ended up going on a
date
she did he wasn't even from l.a
yeah from out of state you guys want to
hear it
it was a good too bad story it wasn't
great to horrendous story it was it
really was
so maybe you also should not meet people
on planes but if you guys have a cute
plane story let me know
or if you're going on a certain flight
in the next couple weeks back to l.a
let me down um
okay we're going to talk a little bit
about our guests that we have coming on
today's show
they are such good friends of ours we
have cameron fuller and greg sulkin
joining us
they are awesome we have both known them
for quite some time
i met cameron first six years ago and
says team that
greg a couple yeah so it's like stories
how we met it's pretty interesting it's
fun we're gonna talk about stories
you know funny experiences they give
advice on a guy's perspective and we
also give advice for
a girl's perspective so stay tuned you
guys today
on unwaxed we have two of our dearest
friends
closer shall i say brothers
we have both actors they're youtubers
best friends
cameron fuller and greg sulkin ladies
and gentlemen
you're welcome oh god and
now designer greg yes by the way just
you know greg it's right here a little
shout out there it's right here you
listen
but you know why is it on the back of
the chair and also why are you wearing
it
and why is it inside out yes listen it's
called breadlock right
i'm not gonna it shrinks a little
sometimes i have to air dry it that's
all
what do you want all right shine already
see this is great this is why we got two
sisters we're gonna fight two dozens
they're gonna fight let's just clarify
that for a second hold on
eighty percent organic hold on
eighty percent organic cotton and
therefore um
like cotton yes ideally if you can air
dry it is better for the material
of course and you're supposed to rinse
it in cold water would you also like to
plug the link and maybe the instagram
where they can find it as well
or no sure i mean
i didn't find it but okay perfect
thank you cameron for the rave review i
appreciate it listen
it's uh i i've never actually had
an article of ida well now i'm nervous
because you got it
um i've never had a piece of clothing
that i have cared about so much that i
don't just throw it in the dryer to dry
where i'm at like i'm gonna hang it up
and i'm gonna air
because i actually i i love i love
gridlock so
it's it's awesome he just redeemed
himself he just redeemed himself
you guys we've been wanting you two
rascals to get on this show since
the very beginning so we're really
excited to thank you guys for taking the
time and coming on today
greg they've had a lot of episodes
though
and they you are such a hater today we
asked you from
since august wait wait he thinks he's
cool now because he has a tattoo
guys he just got a tattoo on his arm
let's see it
now he thinks it's a bit edgy
hold on hold on i can't do it
what do you mean look at that wow
i'm not flexing okay i am he's flexing
he had a celsius people he's ready it
looks great how do you feel now that you
have a tattoo do you feel
more manly i just i don't know
i don't really feel that much different
to be honest with you really
yeah yeah it feels why don't you guys
why don't you guys have tattoos together
matching tattoos that's the name
of each other's initials let's
we'll get there he's like now that he's
insulted my clothing we're done we're
done well you know what
i want to talk about how we all met yes
um sophia i feel like you
how did you get cameron i met cameron
first like
literally i think six years ago right
all right is that crazy yeah when we
meet up what do you guys mean
i met on campus right yes
but no no no we met it we met at um our
friend's
party you were dating a lady at the time
a lady a lady a well-known lady and then
i i was i don't know i think we were
just all hanging out i didn't really
talk to anybody else except
you because you're like one of the
nicest people instantly i just remember
that
oh my god you're such a good fraud i
actually remember that night
so clearly um i remember there was like
a big tent when it was
at a good friend of ours house and we
were like the last ones at the party and
the only ones dancing
that's oh my god you're so right oh this
is why we've been friends for six years
how were the dance moves she was great
me
you know me greg that's right give me a
couple drinks
and i can move but other than that i
think he's i think maybe it was like
the alcohol that made you think i was a
lot better than i actually am i honestly
i thought you were great i knew that
night i was like
sophia is gonna be a lifelong friend
hold on i feel like
now that you guys said that you met sort
of by dancing that's kind of how
i met greg for the first time as well
hold on i'm gonna i'm gonna tell a story
i don't know if you know the story
in full but it is one of the funniest
stories the best story i wanted to share
it on the show but i feel like you had
to be here for it
it's so funny um okay
sophia and i uh we're at a young
hollywood event i want to say this is
four years ago maybe yeah four years ago
and um
we look horrendous i'll explain sophia
is wearing a giant
pink feather boa jacket and a
sparkly pink dress and i look like a
bumble bee because i'm wearing
yellow and black striped leggings yellow
and black stripes
basically the dresser gave us whatever
people did not want
just we looked like the circus rolling
in here everyone else looked cool
um i'm doing my own thing i'm dancing i
see greg i'm like what disney channel
like this is cool
i don't say anything to him goodbye
right yeah
i'm on a dating app he's on a dating app
we match on a dating app
we go to dinner as one does from a
dating app and what you had said
to me oh boy oh boy
i'm not gonna this isn't i'm not gonna
put you on blast right now because this
is one of my favorite memories of all
time
it really is makes me feel good it's so
funny
you were so sweet and such a gentleman
and you were so complimentary and you
said
you know you looked so beautiful at that
event and i was like really
i looked okay thanks and he goes yeah
the pink
furry jacket and that pink dress looked
really nice on you and i was like
oh no that was my sister sophia no no
you got the wrong
no it's okay because we look alike i'll
call her so
no problem you know we were supposed to
go on the date apparently
you know i yeah i realized at the time
that personality is so
important yes and i thought dinner was
was lovely i thought the stylist choice
were great
and steen now thinking about it the
bumblebee outfit
was exceptional i just didn't realize no
it is not your fault it looks like
twitter you look alike
but i just thought it was so hilarious
and like not me and i'm not offended i
thought it was exactly
she was like he felt so bad it was bad
and i was like this friendship
just started i feel like we're all
bickering like siblings like this
oh my god okay let's talk about
something people might be interested in
i want to talk about
your careers both of you you guys are
actors
um and it is one of the toughest
industries to get into
it is extremely you know involved a lot
of egos are involved a lot of
narcissists a lot of fakeness
but it's cool when you get the job i
want to know what do you guys think
is the hardest part that you've found or
if you have a story of it just a
difficult experience that you've had
since
since joining this acting world cam you
want to go first
uh no let you go first
all right cool um i would say you've got
to be really thick skinned to be in this
industry right
always hear the like success stories but
there are so many times when you put
your heart and soul into something and
it just doesn't pan out
and yeah whether it's um you know
it's like when you get knocked down you
have to get back up you have to like
dust yourself off and go again and come
back even stronger
and that's not for everybody some people
don't want to be
rejected on a daily or weekly or monthly
basis
um and so you know it's i think the
hardest thing is like remaining
and and and keeping your self-confidence
and self-belief
yeah but i do think that that applies
for a lot of industries but i think in
acting
it's like you stand there you perform
you do get judged and yeah you feel like
you're just standing there naked
and if they don't like it's not that
they don't like what you can do
they just don't like you that's the
hardest part i don't know how y'all do
it
you know i i do i audition in clothes
but i've never stood there naked
oh no that's not what i meant like
hypothetically naked
[ __ ] little oh my god cameron your
turn
jesus uh
yeah i think i think the the hardest
thing
about acting in in in general
is the uncertainty of what the next
particle is going to be because
you're basing your life based on
performance it's not like a normal job
where you work somewhere for
x amount of years you work very hard and
then you get a promotion
yeah there is
you could be incredibly good but if some
factors don't go your way you're still
sitting there yeah
next audition and that's that's a very
difficult difficult job
and you need really thick skin and you
also need to want it
more than anybody else in the entire
planet
for sure oh yeah being the only
non-actor here um
i would just like to say about the
acting industry that
i think the hardest part of acting is
acting itself because i remember
one time when i went to an acting class
and this is funny
the teacher told me that i was too
pollyanna
and instantly said that you didn't have
enough life experience because i had no
life experience
i was a horrible actress yeah she said
she's explaining life
you're a horrible actress you wear rose
colored glasses this is not right for
you
go get more life experience and i'm with
that very teacher now and i
feel so proud so um i would just like to
say i don't know how you guys pretend to
be other people because i'm obviously
really bad at
oh what was your worst audition
experience you've ever had because i
know sistine has one
that still is the funniest thing ever i
mean it's horrible i think i have more
bad experiences than good experiences
but i'd love to name one experience that
was really bad
go ahead ken yeah i can come on um so
i remember this really clearly because
this rattled me for a very long time
like fully just [ __ ] me up really bad
but um so you both have
come to my birthdays before i love them
when i have a birthday i'm like i get
excited about it i invite my friends
it's like a fun little thing
and um i got an audition
two days before my birthday and i was
like
okay whatever it's fine and i'm just
like i'm not really going to pay
attention to it i'll just
look at the lines last minute i'll go in
and just hope that it goes really well
because it's my birthday and i get
excited about that and looking back on
it i
probably should not have gone in but i
uh
so birthday pass is great weekend it's
like sunday night the audition's monday
morning and i look at it for the first
time
and i look at who's going to be there
and it's the directors and the producers
and the casting director
and like everything hey group big group
right and i look at
the uh besides the pages of the lines
that i need to know and it is
monologue monologue monologue dialogue
for about 12 pages
but you're not ready you start to panic
but at that point
where i was like oh if they if my team
wants to send me in on something i have
to go in i can't call and cancel like i
don't want to
point them yeah go in
first thing the casting director says to
me is you look really tired
big weekend i was like
oh wow was he he probably stalking your
instagram or something you saw he had a
birthday
i i i i guess i looked horrible i'm not
really sure
he's like you look you look exhausted
and i was like
i'm fine like it's all good like let's
get this going the
first thing the director said to me was
oh what'd you think of the script i'm
sure you read it
and i was like okay uh shots fired
i see yeah get it in your head already
this sounds like an internal nightmare
dude
this is like my worst nightmare i've had
a code red
10 out of 10. my heart is throbbing
right so i'm in this room with all these
people
i'm like okay i'll make this quicker
because i feel like there's a long story
but
so i'm like no i didn't read the script
so i feel completely naked like what we
talked about before
like are you also going into rooms naked
no no no
it doesn't help you get the job but it
leaves an impression it does
exactly so i uh read
and i messed up the lines and was
looking down at the page
the entire time to the point where i was
looking up and i saw them like with
their faces like so disgusted that i was
in this room right now and afterwards
they were like almost angry with me and
they're like
yeah thanks and i left
i felt so bad and i remember this is the
first time this ever happened to me
and the last time thank god so far my
entire
the entire agency found out about how
badly my audition was
and everyone on my team like called me
and they're like what the [ __ ] happened
like it became a very big thing okay but
that happened to me by the way
so don't feel so bad that's my
that was my like welcome to auditioning
story
like welcome to the world of acting you
have to forget a line or two
it's like it happens i forgot 12 pages
16
so oh that's not a lie there too it was
your birthday
i wouldn't remember one page yeah
what was your what was your experience
oh my gosh i love
uh okay i think i already told cameron
this story when i went on his podcast
um i got an audition for
uh a spin-off of a movie that is
becoming a tv show and it's horror so i
was like oh
yes this is so me i'm playing like a
sorority girl like yes
this is just me to achieve it was
very simple dialogue but i guess
you know maybe i shouldn't say that now
because clearly it wasn't and
um i guess like i studied i i feel great
about it i go in i
don't really know the proper etiquette
for
going into an audition apparently you're
not supposed to shake their hand
apparently you're not supposed to make
small talk like there's
certain things that i didn't know and i
did all of those things
and i think that just bothered them a
little bit i don't imagine you you just
no you don't understand i walk in i'm
making comments about the art on their
walls
like why like why okay this is my film
too
i'm like oh my god is that from the
movie big eyes like i've seen it
i would have done that acting so like i
know my cinematic knowledge
and um i do it and she goes okay can you
maybe read it like not like that
like this i go oh [ __ ] i can i'm a
chameleon i can do anything
so i did it again i feel like that was
great thank you so much
i walk out feeling fantastic i get a
call 8 a.m the next morning
from my managers and normally that's a
good call
because i've never gotten like a bad
call at 8 a.m that's normally like you
got the job
uh quite the opposite so i answer like
hello and they're like 16
um what happened yesterday and i was
like well i walked in i made a comment
they said i did great and i left
so tell me i got the job and they said
well quite the opposite really um what
did you say exactly because they
described it as
stupid and i go um
oh well what do you mean wait hold on i
go
i go well what do you mean like my
audition was stupid or or i was stupid
and they go
they didn't say you didn't ask
hold on like you didn't ask what was so
stupid they go
no looks you just hung up i'll go okay
now i got a problem with you guys too
so i go call him back call back this
freaking casting person
and they said oh well that i guess that
was the wrong choice but all of her
choices were unintelligent
and her remarks were um not the
brightest
and i go okay so stupid cool thank you
have a nice life
goodbye who asked about the art on the
wall that was it
i i don't know i i thought you're
supposed to like schmooze them
that's just not no no no you're not
apparently you're just the absolute
that's how much i know
it was rough wow i'm guessing you have
not been
back into that casting office since oh
if i go back to that if i get called
back to that home i'm going to tp them
i'm going to egg their house oh yeah i'm
still upset a few years later
do you have a bad experience oh no great
i do i do it was a
um you know it was at the time it's it's
like
soul crushing but now i would never put
up with it i just wouldn't
but um at the time
i was really i was like young i was new
to la
and it was like a it was an audition for
like i think a cop show
to play like this kid who i can't
remember the character but anyway i went
in
and the guy the casting director
i remember it was a small office he's
sitting behind his desk
and he's like like reading a bunch of
papers and i'm like
like in my mind i'm like like this is my
time
right like ready to go and
then like as as i start like my first
line in he goes
like he's eating an apple and i'm like
what do i do at this point do i continue
do i not continue like
is does he want to take a lunch break
like what's this guy's deal
does not look up does not look up at all
does not look at me one
eating uh his apple at the time
continuing to eat the apple after i
finished i did the scene
and goes like this it's still like
reading the thing and he goes thank you
and i just was just like now i would at
the time i was just like
oh my god like i i did so bad blah blah
blah but now i would
handle it extremely different and i
would genuinely just say
look like if you want me to come back
i'm happy you don't like
it like i don't need to keep going yeah
just like i'm not gonna waste my time if
you're not even gonna respect the time
you guys give really sound advice um so
that's why i wanted to
ask you you know from like a
brother to a sister kind of
have had very long relationships and
like successful ones
yeah well we're on the topic of it
because so tell us what things like
we're doing yeah what are we doing wrong
and let us know what men really want
okay hypothetically you boys are on a
first date right
you're getting sushi not with each other
right not with each other
no no no you could be on like a double
date
if you want to pretend so
you guys are on a date what on this
first date
are things that you like that you
normally see from your experience of
what you you know like and don't like it
what are the things that you're like uh
turn off it doesn't work for me i would
say
uh i would say
values humor humor is a must you gotta
you gotta have some
uh okay gotta have some banter but yeah
banter
humor um values
like do you share sort of the same right
values which yes i'd like to think most
people you meet sort of do
be kind to people you know do good in
the world
um and then
um red flags what's a red flag perfume
is important you know
like perfume yeah so smell smell okay
so greg's is good smell banter funny
good values okay cameron what are you
looking for
i think um i think when you're at dinner
with somebody
and you lose track of time
on your watch and like
no i i know that that sounds super
cheesy
but it's so sweet by the way by the way
now [ __ ] and i have said this
if i use all of my funny jokes and all
of my slingers right
in the first date then it's not a good
date
because i'm trying too hard i like that
okay honestly like
i feel like so for you it's like
you shouldn't have to try too hard it's
like if it's like an if it's an organic
thing that could work it's not even
really about like telling
those jokes it's just whatever you feel
and then it works and
you leave being like wow i wish i could
stay
i love that yeah so let's talk the
opposite sorry sorry to jump in sorry to
jump in but
um sophia i really want to know what
those like i think you called them
slingers
what are those what are the things i
would like to know
okay so when it gets really boring um
i start to throw out fun facts that i
know
that dad has told us and i i do that too
and it works
yeah and i said that
did you know wait that doesn't mean you
said or you say like
do you you were saying she's used this
i've used it like recycle them
so i would say that do you know who
invented
the toilet yes oh
no why would i know who would know that
who would know that no
i don't know maybe you use it every day
so you should know um
and then he goes i'm not sure that one
necessarily hits
that way wait let me you haven't even
finished the part i haven't even hit the
punch line yet
and this is what it's like really bad
because it's kind of honestly
when that you hear this it's really it
makes sense of why i'm ending the date
like this
i go so do you know who invented toilets
to go no i go okay
great um did you know his name is
thomas crawford rapper thomas crawford
so where did the term crap come from
thomas crapper yeah yeah don't
know that did you know that look at
their faces
oh my gosh right i want you to know i
had a good time on this podcast we need
to go
right we have to do a thing every person
i've said this to
has said wait that's actually pretty
cool to me there's never been a second
date
no i know why you're seeing their faces
that's not true i've said it before
mine is worse but mine is worse by the
way
what's yours mine's worse is this the
this is the whale one
oh yeah this is a fun fact though these
are fun facts no but it's
i'm not talking about feces but i'm also
talking about another bodily fluid so i
don't know if it's much better
man no but we're on the right page we're
on the right page
here we go okay let's go all right it's
getting a little dry or someone doesn't
know to pay for the bill i say all right
answer me this question
answer me this question how much
sperm do you think a whale produces
in one ejaculation boys i'm asking you
yes i never thought about it please
inform me
uh greg i think you should guess how
much
uh are we talking like pounds like
what we'll talk you know in terms of
either cups liters
pints gallons i would say yeah i would
say
i'd say a cop i'd say a gallon
okay
that's a lot uh greg says a cop you say
a gallon
cameron normal men do a cup
that would actually i feel like there's
some crazy answer to this question so
i'm going to say
five gallons try 400 gallons
whoa and you wonder why it's so salty in
the ocean let's move on let's move on
let's move on
let's move on let's move along
guys okay wait hold on you you uh you
asked us for
for some advice for you both right like
wait so red flags to
get your number one red flag and your
number one red flag
those you just fed them yes
you guys would think they're so funny if
we threw that out no they think we're
psychotic
okay so obviously that's a red flag
don't say weird facts
maybe you do if i heard those maybe an
uber home i'll tell you
i'll tell you a red flag i'll tell you a
red flag okay
if someone is on their phone
during a meal it's a red flag for me
mm-hmm
good so if it's even off the table i
think that's better
not even on the table yeah hold on hold
on hold on
no great greg is someone that has his
phone on the table
it's probably like flipped over but it
also vibrates
it's like the ringer is off but the
vibration is on are you really going to
go at me right now are you
sure i'm not going to it's just a
question first date
i understand but that's what we're
talking about okay first thing okay
so what's your big red flag greg um
talking about thomas crapper number one
[Music]
he didn't forget he didn't forget it now
you're gonna watch us you're gonna go
home and you're gonna tell your friends
you're gonna see a toilet and you're
saying
thanks thomas yeah wow yeah guys
i just wanted to know that i've known
that joke for so long and so many people
know that joke that's not like a very
original one
you knew that there was a guy named
thomas crapper and that's where crap
came from do you swear
attitude thomas crapper obviously
invented the toilet that's a no
okay okay okay okay hold this hold this
so
um i don't remember what war
specifically i'm not going to give dates
because i don't want to sit down why is
this like a bad fact battle but
but um this sergeant or captain whatever
it was
when his men were tired and needed
some um release he got them ladies of
the night
to help them out right his name
was sergeant pucker sergeant pogba
did you know that i guess you did not
that i didn't know and i'm impressed i'm
impressed that's pretty cool
and i've said that too when i've used
both of those on the first date
right now well because it makes me i
think about the dates i've had that i've
used both
yes i remember the such bad dates that i
was so bored
um guys i have i have a red flag
okay but i feel like you guys definitely
uh
you guys are just you guys probably
don't do this but i feel that naturally
obviously every single person's
circumstance in life is
different right so like like thankfully
if i go out for dinner i'm able to like
pick up the bill however i know that
some people may
not have a job right now et cetera et
cetera so it's all
circumstantial but i think that if
i think it's the gesture
oh i'm kind of traditional so i i would
pick up the bill on a first date
um but i would definitely appreciate and
notice
if the girl did not at least
offer to okay
i get what you're saying i would like to
touch on that so it's
it's it's more about the fake like oh
well let me just look in my
purse and it's just the idea the gesture
of doing it but you would never let her
like she's like i was just getting my
lipstick
without making the guys seem like
because i know he he eventually i've had
guys that made me pay for it
but i've also have had experiences where
the guy also felt kind of like
threatened by the fact that i was gonna
pay for it too because you know what i'm
saying i don't know maybe it's a
confidence level but
if you see the girl like actually
leaning towards her
back or anything just instantly go now i
have this today so are you guys saying
these are red flags because you've both
experienced
those exact uh stories on dates
again no one's spoken to me about whale
sperm or
so that you really haven't been on a bad
date then no
it's not so bad i don't classify as bad
dates i classify it as a very
interesting date and one you will never
forget because you're gonna always
remember the girl that talked about
whale sperm and crack and pokers
definitely not gonna forget oh my god i
think it's a win-win i don't know
yeah but yeah it happens right in the
sense of like it's just
it's just more the the respect that like
i i get the traditional aspect because i
am traditional but yeah the
the gesture it means more than the
dollar amount to me yeah i totally agree
with that all
a lot of our dms are about females
they're asking like
you know what makes me girlfriend
material and he says you know like what
can i do to stand out in terms i get a
lot of outfit questions so from your
guys points of view like what do you
think is like a great
thing a girl can wear that makes her
stand out or a color that's like oh my
god like
she's or a hairstyle or something
i'm more i'm more of the like the less
is more approach
i think simplicity is key i i i don't
i'm
i've never really been drawn to uh
uh wait let me rephrase that um i
i i yeah i think so simplicity's key
and i think there's something you know
like trying to stand out
i don't think anyone should just try to
stand out i think that they should just
be comfortable enough in their own skin
to then not have to feel like they have
to stand there okay
so you showed up in a tight little red
dress on the first yeah that's a little
too much
yes is there a color is it ridiculous
watch them say black um i do like black
but i also to be honest i love like
jeans and a t-shirt i think there are
certain colors that just
pop i guess i'm not really you know
the the reds red pops i like that
notice that neither of you said blue or
black
well on that note gentlemen thank you
for coming on the podcast today
i have spoken about this in the past but
you guys like i know i think we've told
you this before but like
really proud of you guys you guys are
like really
lovely people and i love the fact that
you guys are sending an amazing example
to other young women out there starting
their own business like i think you guys
are fantastic and we're happy to come on
thanks
oh well thank you so much that's really
sweet cameron you're turning everybody
yeah
what's our compliment what i was gonna
say is
sophia obviously as you know i
have been an advocate for you guys like
teaming up and doing a podcast for
years and he did do that yeah
i knew it would be something great like
i just have always felt that and i'm so
glad you guys are doing it because it's
awesome
thanks guys that's really sweet thank
you guys for taking the time
and we'll definitely get on that text
change just to talk about um
progression in future dates yes and and
maybe better one-liners for us and also
let's hang out soon six feet apart
a little so thank you guys so much we do
love these two so much like they are
you guys are awesome plug where everyone
can find you your instagrams tweeters
well um
greg and i have a youtube channel
together which we upload videos every
week and it's the greg and cameron
channel
and then uh you can find me at cameron
fuller everywhere
beautiful and uh yeah same for me
just just my name and obviously if
people are listening and want to check
out gridlock
uh the website is gridlockbrand.com so
and a new collection is coming out in
the next few weeks so steve
very cool thank you guys we love you
both we hope to see you guys soon
love you guys thanks for having us of
course bye